hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on my
house Charlie video everyone's really
excited to meet Sam balls family I'm
hoping they turn into a version of the
Tyrells you know people that you meet a
little bit in one season then become
much bigger in the following season I
think a lot of that will just depend on
how much they follow their book plot
other questions though careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen season five
yet here we go Jamie asks who do you
think the first houses decide with Danny
will be do you think there'll be any
major houses that would actively oppose
her well I think you know the houses to
support Danny first would be the ones
that hate the existing powers-that-be
namely the Baratheon you know which
represent the crown and the Lannisters
so who hates the Lannisters the most
right now I would say the mark tells are
towards the top of the list if not at
the actual top the Starks are probably
at the actual top but there's not much
of a house stark right now they're all
kind of scattered to the four winds you
could lump the Tyrells in there too but
they already have a claim to the throne
through Marjorie so if donairs came in
they'd definitely be out it'd be kind of
hilarious if tanaris did come in in the
Tyrells backed away they said okay you
know Marjorie you can't be queen anymore
but they tried to marry one of the other
Tyrell Sons tour even though the show
hasn't done all the Tyrells sons they
could magic some up just be like oh we
just you know we hadn't introduced them
yet but they still exist and we can
probably assume that the biggest
opposition to Denarius would be the
Lannisters just because they control the
throne right now next question MDB asks
so you actually had like a really long
question that i'm just going to condense
down you just asked me like how fast to
the White Walkers going to make it to
the wall because it seems like they
should be moving faster than they
actually are during the Battle of
hardhome we see the Knights can order an
army of whites over that cliff so it's
pretty clear they can move really fast
if there's only going to be eight
seasons then I would hope that they
would actually spend all of season 8
south of the wall me you'd be like a
season 7 WTF moment I know of at least
two big battles that are probably
happening in season 6 in different
places so I'm not expecting a repeat of
the Battle of hardhome I mean I think
we'll see White Walkers but I don't
think it's going to be the exact same
type of thing where there's like a big
fight with them but what we might see at
the end of season six is them in I shot
of the wall as in oh my god the right
here but then you know save like the big
you know wall crashing moment till
season 7 it's one of those things we
know is going to happen it's just we
don't know how fast they're going to
make it happen they could drag it out as
much as they want that there's
definitely some confirmed WTF stuff
happening
off of the wall in season six so they
might just use those for their big
action set-pieces if you look at big
blockbuster movies sometimes studios
will do that like if they have a couple
really big hits and they make billions
and billions of dollars in a year but
they know they have another big hit that
they're going to be releasing later
sometimes they'll hold that movie till
the next year they actually ended up
doing that with one of the Harry Potter
films Warner Brothers made too much
money in one year because of dark night
so they actually pushed a Harry Potter
film that had been finished to the next
year like I just sat on a shelf so that
Warner Brothers could guarantee a hit in
a non Dark Knight year it's kind of hard
to say how big their army needs to be
because it doesn't seem like it takes
very long for the night's king to raise
new whites and in each individual white
Walker can do that themselves anyway so
even if their undead army isn't that big
they could go into battle against
another force and ask people die raise
them so it's just like you slowly turn
the tide and the army gets bigger and
bigger through the course of said battle
next question Zuri asks how old is
gillies baby at the end of season 5 I
wonder why the baby isn't a taller yet
that's like the same thing where it's
like how come Sam well hasn't lost
weight if he's been at the wall for so
long and there's no food I think what
they're doing with the baby at a
simplicity sake is just kind of
compressing time and saying you know it
hasn't been a full year but it is
getting bigger so if Gilly and the baby
end up surviving to season eight I do
think that we will see a recast actor
like we'll see a much bigger child next
question Tim asks i'm at you actually
had two questions i'm going to answer
the second one how are the charlie
brothers in terms of Brotherly bond i
would say i would say fairly normal
Sam's brother isn't really fleshed out
in the books tab much but he seems like
your typical bro he doesn't come off as
a giant the way randyll Tarly
does but he seems like a pretty typical
teenager so unless the TV show changes
something I think they'll have a
relatively normal relationship like the
same kind of relationship he has with
his sisters and his mother I think most
of the fire in his family is going to be
coming from Randall next question though
crystal asks do you think that his
father might be slightly proud of saying
because he's trying to become a maester
I would say you know definitely not at
all like he actually forbid him from
becoming a maester according to sam i
think the big question is is what is
that family reunion going to be like
like hey what are you doing here oh I
came to be a maester wait you mean that
thing that I told you that you were
never allowed to do what will probably
end up happening
is that his father will disown him and
the rest of his family will be gently
accepting of his situation as well as
Gillian the baby next question Jay asks
do you think there'll be a flashback
more specifically Tarly zero laz
loyalists in the rebellion we know
there's going to be at least one
flashback it's been all say unofficially
confirm just because it looks like
they're doing the Tower of joy scene but
I don't think that's going to be Tarly
related they could totally do other
flashbacks but Danny did you know a long
time ago Danny they were like we're not
doing flashbacks they were lenten they
did the Circe flashback in season five
and it looks like they're at least doing
the Arthur Dayne flashback at the Tower
of joy but I'll say no to Charlie
flashback I think you know most of the
flashbacks will be central to like the
bigger characters like Jon Snow maybe
Daenerys but but really Daenerys doesn't
get flashbacks she gets vision so maybe
we'll see some more dragon visions the
problem is the more flashbacks you do
the less special they get it just
becomes a really casual thing like oh
we're just gonna do a flashback for
every single thing next question Melissa
asks episode nine or Barry end of
episode 10 when something huge happens
Jon Snow resurrection the Jon Snow stuff
will probably happen way sooner than
that just based on stuff that's been
happening in and around the set and
rumors we've been hearing this year we
had hard home in episode 8 that episode
9 we had dro Khan add as next pit in the
nepeta we had the Jon Snow death those
were all pretty successful so I think
they're actually going to try and do the
same thing we're just like it's no one
specific big moment they're just several
over a couple of episodes next question
luan asks since they've taken out a lot
from the books do you think they're
going to do away with the great Meister
conspiracies if you haven't read the
books there's just a theory that the
maesters are the arch maesters of the
Citadel have their own agenda that goes
beyond the people that they serve in
Westeros if you don't know about
maesters their relationship is typically
subservient like a maester will go serve
the lord of a castle anybody that rules
the castle so like if they're serving a
Tyrell and someone goes and takes the
castle from the Tyrell they'll serve the
new person that controls the castle
there are theories though that the arch
maesters have their own ideas about the
direction that Westeros should be taking
there hasn't really been any evidence of
that on the show so I am just assuming
that they're completely doing away with
that but the real test of that will be
what happens whenever Samwell goes to
the Citadel so once season six starts we
should learn pretty quickly depending on
whatever Samwell arrives there next
question cross
asks what do you think about the pink
letter who do you think wrote it and
what is its real purpose well it's real
purpose was just a goat Jon Snow into a
war now the pink letter is something
that the show hasn't really done but
they might end up doing the plotline
later in the books it just it happened
before he was murdered the pink letter
itself is just a letter that's written
on pink parchment the Jon Snow reads in
the letter Ramsey implies that he's
killed Stannis defeated his army is
holding Mance Rayder captive and he has
married John's sister Arya Stark so he
take the letter of face value and you
think that Ramsey wrote it it's just him
saying I've defeated Stannis's army come
and get some bring me back what's mine
if you believe someone else wrote it
like Mance Rayder or little finger and
it's them trying to go Jon Snow into
taking care of the Ramsay Bolton problem
of the Bolton's in general I'm inclined
to think that the show is just gonna
play it straight Ramsey will be the
person that will send the letter that
will go Jon Snow into a battle but it's
totally possible that Littlefinger could
get off his ass and do something about
it it seems like something that he would
do like try to play two big forces
against each other he's already trying
to play the crown against the Bolton's
next question anshu asks isn't Sam no
longer a knight's card if he says he
fathered a child with Gilly does that
mean that he'll be a contender to horn
he'll know Samwell is still gonna be
part of the Nights Watch I don't think
that he's gonna have enough time to
become a maester anyway so I don't think
it's going to be an issue he'll still
probably be bound to his oath to the
Nights Watch even if that weren't the
case I don't think that he would want
horn Hill anyway I don't I don't think
he's someone that craves power I think
he'd be happy to abdicate that to his
brother as long as he got to live with
Gilly I think gillies what he really
wants aside from saving the kingdom from
certain doom but thank you everyone for
so many questions he's always a ton of
fun to do there has been a lot of
pictures from the set I'm not going to
do a whole lot of spoilery videos about
stuff like that unless it's like
something that I can talk about in a non
spoilery way so if there's anything that
you have big questions about that I have
an answer just let me know in the
comments there's still a lot of filming
to be done so we're just going to
continue to see pictures from the set so
don't be surprised if you hear about
like really big characters doing big WTF
things you know beware of spoilers
though if you go looking for that stuff
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Missa seven you win a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so i can get your contact
info we're still a couple weeks
way from a night of the Seven Kingdoms
being released in the United States once
that does drop I'll just replace the
give away with that you guys may have
been reading about some house Tyrell
stuff happening lately on the internet
you can actually click here to learn
about a history of their family and you
can click here to learn all about
resurrection in a game of thrones and
Song of Ice and Fire thank you so much
watching everybody let's high pop I'll
see you guys tonight
you